esta es la primera cumbre cara a cara en
dos años desde que inició la pandemia y
que cuenta con extremas medidas de
bioseguridad y que busca que los países
más poderosos las economías más fuertes
así como las democracias más grandes
aporten ideas para que los países en
desarrollo puedan superar la crisis que
ha dejado en todo el mundo el kobe 19 en
la sesión de hoy los ministros de
exteriores abordarán la influencia cada
vez más creciente de la china de irán y
de rusia así como el peligro de lo que
decir consideran para las democracias
para los derechos humanos y para las
libertades en el caso de rusia se
hablará sobre 'el opositor' alexéi
navalni y el aumento de las tropas en la
frontera con ucrania también se
analizará la delicada situación para los
derechos humanos en myanmar después del
golpe de estado de febrero de este año
en esa nación del sudeste asiático se
espera que estos países aumenten la
presión sobre la junta militar para
obligar el regreso a la
esta será además la cumbre preparatoria
de la que se realizará aquí también en
el reino unido en jornal en el próximo
mes de junio de los mandatarios de los
líderes de estos países del g7 este será
también el primer viaje al exterior del
presidente de eeuu joe biden